so we'll kick off it is now six o'clock
um any apologies lateness is leaving
early
nope conflicts of interest to declare
philip uh yes madam chair i may be on
the district licensing committee
for a hearing so i'll take no part in
relation to the
deputation and item four thank you
phillip
any other conflicts of interest right
the minutes of the last meeting
already had a read of them any questions
somebody like to move that they'd be
accepted
thank you john seconded by mark
right any problems with them
no matters writing yes
i haven't passed a minute yet right all
those in favor of uh
confirming the minutes uh please say aye
those against
that's carried matters arising andrea
6.2 um the update screening board
standing orders
um in paragraph three um
jim palmer noted that my suggestion
about adding additional order
in regards to the capacity and coherence
of a board member that would need wider
consideration i would like to actually
have that miniature that i would like
that looked into as to what we would
need to do
to actually entertain that
thank you madam chair you've got that
one
right anything else under matters
arising
right we have two deputations from the
community tonight
and we will kick off with narinda from
the titano enterprises
please come to the table at the end
there and
share your business plan with us thank
you phillip
[Music]
hello everyone my name is gurpreet singh
dillon and
i'm the one of the director for titi no
enterprises limited and with me my
business partner
partner narendra sang and just want to
pass you something about myself i
actually i'm working as a
store manager in liquor center from last
five and a half year
in christchurch and i'm the only one who
is looking after that water store
as my owner he lives in australia and
i'm the one who is organizing each and
everything
and we are bringing here the liquor
center uh
wooden the liquor center is one of the
fastest growing
liquor chain in new zealand with over
235 stores
nationwide and they are proudly
new zealand owned and operated family
they sub support and
are part of local communities they are
big on being local so is the only true
independent liquor chain
in new zealand they have a very good
track records and a
zero tolerance and there
and some of our things which nanda is
going to share with you
regarding the business plan and other
things thank you
thank you gurpreet uh good evening
everyone
my name is narendra singh wadat uh i'm
the one of the director of trading
enterprises
so before sharing our business plan i
would like to introduce
myself properly with the board um
by work i own couple of hospitality
business one in emberly and one in
wooden
so we are running them early from 2017
so i'm pretty well known
by this area so uh
the wooden one uh the big bite pizza
where we put the application for off
lessons
so yeah so with the my professional work
i also do
a lot of community and social work uh
i'm the president of canterbury punjabi
association that's a community group
we organized a lot of social event and
do social work
last couple of years we done a lot of
work
after most attack and kobe 19
and a motion in new zealand parliament
was run in
may 2019 to acknowledge our work
and thanks to me and my association so
with this um i'm also a white ribbon
ambassador
obviously as ambassador i stand against
domestic violence
so regarding our business plan
um as jim grpd mentioned we are bringing
the franchisee of the liquor center
which is totally
new zealand owned and they are local
so obviously uh we got
some objections and people have concern
regarding
another bottle store in in the town
so this is a growing town according to
2018 census
like a wooden population around 2800
and legally after 1000 population
only uh liquors shop fall in the
category and then we have a cocoa beach
and we have a couple of small suburbs
all around
um for me to come in the liquor industry
that's my first venture i would like to
tell you
um actually i'm the just a backbone uh
gurpreet is
in charge of all liquor operation as he
got the experience
um for me i think um
i'm pretty in i would not say inspired
but
i think i like the model of maybe you
guys hear about the licensing trust
uh material licensing trust in gore
and the inward argument licensing trust
uh in inward cargill
where all the margin go back to the
community
like if we talk about matrua lessons in
trust like up to 31st march 2019
they gave back 90 million back to the
community
to support the sports to support the
schools
to support the community so my model for
the wood and liquor store is
almost same so we decided to give our
twenty percent profit back to the wooden
community
in which five percent will go for the
local school and preschool uh
sponsorship
five percent would go to the local
wooden fire station
five percent would go to the sport this
community center
and another five percent will go for to
support the
uh local community initiatives so
um i think when we talk about liquor
obviously there is a
licorice for the entertainment and
most of the people we drink alcohol are
personally myself not uh
but yeah but there is a we need good
people in this industry
and we need the people who who run not
like a business
just uh with this thought to serve the
community
so this is my plan my vision for the
local community if i'm here i will
support the local community initiatives
so after this if you guys have any
questions or any suggestion for my
application
please feel free to ask i'm here for all
your questions
today
right any questions anyone
i i just like to say we have no
questions for anyone so i'd just like to
say thank you very much for for coming
along tonight and
and sharing your business plan um and
yes you're very welcome to stay but
you know feel free to leave thank you
very much and thanks once again for your
time
to speak us and yeah thanks again
can you bring can you get philippine
james but we have
a deputation from james ensor who's come
to talk to us about
signage for life saving club hours over
the summer season
[Music]
james
i should remember this technology i'm
james easter i've been involved in this
area for a long time
probably about 20 years um to try and
get good outcomes
and i still take a real interest in the
surf patrols to see that we get
good outcomes at the beaches and we
don't see a drowning in any of the
surf patrol areas and get make sure we
get funding as well
so what we're proposing to do is we've
had a lot of trouble over the last 10
years getting
assigned to stay in pegasus and with the
different owners there it's been very
difficult
and we love the sign you put up i just
didn't get a fancy presentation i just
draw
some pictures along which you can see
the lovely sign you've got with pegasus
town on i think it's great and the
planting around the bottom and what we'd
like to do is put a sign virtually
opposite that
with the surf patrol on i'll show you
the site of that in a minute
and just put the planting around the
side there and we think if you do that
it'll
also help to calm the traffic down going
and if you've got to sign each side
we've then got a site which we're
proposing which is virtually opposite
there
which is where that jacket is you can
probably see the jacket just here
it's inside where the trees are and it's
just near where the fence is where the
underpass is under the road and we had
ian kennedy from roading team who does
all the signs for
last 20 or 30 years and he had a look
and he said it has no visual effects on
traffic and safety and things like that
so he thinks it's an ideal site
this is the sort of sign we want to put
up which has the dates and the
times and things of the surf patrols
this will be one
and then we'll have another one down
further and then we'll have one on the
toilets down at the beach
and we'll have one up on rangioram road
so we just want to
give all of the community a chance to
see the dates and times and when the
activities are
and if we have it in that location it
actually gets all the house
houses and the people traveling to their
houses
i'm happy to answer any questions but it
would just look just to refresh you
it would look like this some funding if
you want to do it we wonder whether the
community would perhaps plant it and
perhaps
the community board would apply for some
funding from that
landscaping budget and end up with
something similar to this because it
would look
a bit hackery if you ended up with
something completely different and i
think that looks really good now
and we can't put our sign back on there
now because there's too many plants
and it's really too low and each time
we've had it in a low location it's got
damage so if we have it up higher which
it'll be like a giveaway sign
it'll be just a wee bit higher than what
this is on the other side i'm actually
slowly get damaged
i have to answer any questions and um
i'm there to represent the community and
try and get a good outcome
thanks james questions from anyone
i'll pass these quickly around if you
want to have a quick look too that might
be a good idea
um james just whereabouts on the state
hall a1 is this
one around my pegasus this is on the
road going into pegasus that silence
so it's not on the state highway no this
is on the
roadway going into pegasus town and it's
a residence sign that's on the opposite
side where the walkway is
it's between the golf club and where the
first
about is going into the town
okay okay and we had it on the opposite
side
okay that's fine thank you we had on the
opposite side last year but it was not a
very satisfactory site
okay that's great thank you have a good
look at that uh you'll pick it up
any other questions from anyone
i just want to say thank you james and
yes i think we'll we will um
i mean i would like to see that we call
for a report um
from staff around the sign and
landscaping around the bottom of it we
do have money in the landscaping budget
so that is actually a possibility
for that it has been an issue in the
past
so the sign does get
damaged and it is certainly something
that is really of bringing to people's
attention
what the surf lifesaving club hours
actually are over the summer
so thank you very much james no that's
that's fine um we did have
we did have um a sign that was smaller
which we had up um
but it got damaged as well thank you
very much
any adjourned business
reports we've got first up is the
wooden shared path
welcoming to you both good evening
um so following on from our presentation
a month so ago we carried out two
drop-in sessions
and also public consultation with the
residents directly involved
the school as and the bowling club
we received 34 submissions in total
eight of them were in favor of option
one uh and 26 of them were in
favor of option two which was shifting
the
lanes in that wide area
i've got some um the pictures are there
if you need to see them
um following on from that to allow the
shared path to be installed
we're looking to install some um no
parking lines opposite terrafy here road
we also carried out consultation with
the affected property owners in that
area
and they had no concerns the resident at
number 128 just wanted one parking space
outside his driveway which we've
provided um
and yeah following on that we never had
any negative feedback
um so our next step would like to be
proceed with
detailed design if there's any questions
any questions from anyone philip
thank you madam chair i've actually
discovered why i didn't have your
diagrams
glenn i've got one of cone strength
and diligent wasn't very helpful
of the people who were
supported option one i got the
impression that they were the properties
that were affected if option 2
was chosen was there any way of
mitigating
the concerns of the people opposed to
option 2
simply because it went past their place
or they were worried about
access and so on was there
any consideration given there so the
most the ones that opposed a couple of
them
were to do with financial costs i don't
think they quite understood
that option one or option two would be
cheaper
there was a couple that were concerned
about it being the carriageway being
pushed closer to their property
but there is no difference to any other
carriageway in the district
at the moment is about seven meters from
driveway to edge of
lane whereas we're proposing to put it
to
about three and a half meters
[Music]
any other questions i actually have
a couple um
school road well um
[Music]
trucks
all right school road we actually have
trucks turn
traveling north they turn off state
highway one come down ringy or a wood
end road and then
turn into school road and park
up this end of school road to be able to
access
the toilets and the shops will trucks
still be able to
get turn right into school road i mean
is there going to be enough
room for trucks to get around there
uh yep so we've got tracking curves on
it and trucks will still be able to get
in although that was one of the concerns
that one of the residents had raised was
the amount of trucks that come down
there
a to access the public toilet which is
down there yeah
and then he also had concerns about them
turning left from school road on to
wrangler audience road and cutting that
corner where people wait
yeah so we've actually put a build out
through there to try and
mitigate that yeah that's right yeah the
truck drivers they stopped to use the
toilet but also to go to the shops to
get something for their lunch so
there's quite a few trucks actually do
do that um
my other question is the cycle
the shared path comes as far as sort of
the entrance into the school
so just along here from the community
centre
and then there's nothing after that and
yet my understanding was it was going to
come up to stay at highway one and then
join up with the signalised pedestrian
crossing is that part of this project
uh yeah so this we're looking to also um
widen that section from the school to
state highway one by about half a metre
which will just allow for that
additional traffic which will then link
into
nzta signalized crossing
um is it possible to do something with
um the shared path around chinery's road
intersection
it was raised by one of the respondents
who talked about at the moment when
traffic is
heading towards rangiora downranging
road turning right into
chile's road traffic behind them is
coming around on the inside
and actually going on to the shared path
because there's actually nothing to stop
them it's actually sealed
right across at that point is there
something that could be done
to make that safer
uh yes there is um and we are looking
for that was actually raised in the
safety order from when that
would enter ringing or a path was first
constructed and
we are working through a list of minor
improvements including that intersection
and that may be included in this
contract or it might be passed to
cyclone to do
sooner rather than later um so we're
still working through and prioritizing
the list
of remedial works today yeah it is
actually quite
an important one because there is a lot
of there's more and more traffic turning
right into china's road there
so it is becoming quite a safety issue
so what we're looking at doing is
painting um
diagonal shoulder markings from the end
of the where the build out is now where
the path
currently ends running that probably
around about a one and a half meter
painted shoulder
up towards rangiora and two concrete
islands one on each side of
um opposite the intersection with some
signage saying
basically keep right so that's
yeah quite happy to also just take some
feedback on if you think that
is a suitable solution as well
sounds it okay
any other questions from anyone
right anyone like to move something
thank you john so john's moved option
two be the one that
we put forward do i have a seconder for
that
thank you mark john would you like to
speak to that
right any other discussion around that
for me just for a point of clarification
it was mentioned that of the
yellow lines or the was that um
i just didn't i didn't have a big issue
with it but that was part of your paper
wasn't it
yeah so i just want to make any comment
was there any
um particular objection i think one
neighbor was
sensitive to it one wasn't it but you
had a solution
for them is that right uh yeah so the
um the resident at 128 he
wanted to have a park so i have
reduced that radius just to allow a car
park outside his driveway
the resident at 118 had a lot of
off-street parking and a lot of land
that he could use so he didn't have any
concerns with it he actually noted that
most of the traffic that parked there
are truck trailers that are just left
there
overnight
[Music]
thank you madam chair um i'm in favour
of
option two i'd like to congratulate
glenn on his
uh work and colleagues
and getting to this point cycleways
greenways whatever they're called can be
quite problematic with residents when
you're trying to retrofit one into
an existing area the advantage here was
that there is plenty of carriageway
that could be used and i'm pleased that
staff have taken on board the concerns
of residents
on that basis um the preference for
option two
was quite overwhelming from the feedback
that's been received
so it looks hopefully fingers crossed
like a job well done
thank you
i'm also in support of um the motion
with option two
um very impressed with with the feedback
that you've got that you got from the
community
and how favorable it was actually just
to the whole concept
of extending the cycle way
and you've got a lot of users of it too
who provided feedback which is really
really good to see
and i look forward to it so
anybody else got anything they'd like to
say
right i'll put that to the vote so that
is
6.1 a through to
g
that we are voting on so all those in
favor say aye
those against that's carried
thank you very much it was a good report
and it was good consultation
and yeah fingers crossed
thank you
scott road naming welcome back
uh thank you very much everyone um so
yeah
so to start with um the first purpose of
the report is to consider adding a new
road names to the pre-approved list of
potential road names in the wooden theft
and community board area
so this report has come about because
amendment has been made
um in order to change one of the
suggested names after consultation with
the
prep family since the previous board
meeting on the 14th of september
so i will take it you've had the
opportunity to read the report and i
will look forward to any questions you
may have
questions anyone
must have been a good reporter any
motion and philip has seconded it andrew
do you want to say anything to it
uh thank you madam chair i think it's
good that we are using
names that are connected with the
district
and in this case i actually know both
bnc families so i think it's quite
appropriate
especially robinson that's a well-known
family in the district there were
a large number of robinsons so when
it might be named after either robinson
but there are other
siblings and so on that will benefit
from that name being used
so betty wright that appears to be a
change from betty rainey i'm assuming
right it's her maiden name
so that overcomes any duplication with
rainey
so um i think there are two good names
to be added to the list
anyone else got anything to say right
i'll put that motion to the vote all
those in favor say aye
those against that one's carried
scott your next report on pegasus fields
yes so um the purpose of this report is
to
consider naming a new private right away
which is created as part of rural
subversion
comprising of seven new lots the land
puzzle being developed as
uh 158 ashby's road belkin
um so i take it we have opportunity to
read it once again and i will look for
any questions you may have around
it thanks right questions from anyone
hello uh scott
how desirable is it to name
streets after contractors in various
developments i mean it could be lawyers
could be contractors
there's no direct connection with the
area apart from their involvement with
the subdivision so
is that something that you would
recommend or has occurred
in the past um yeah so basically what
basically what happens in the process is
that
the developer puts forward some names
and we submit them and i guess it's
i mean we where we check them as as if
there's no names
already existing in the district if it's
not a duplicate name that sort of thing
as far as the name where it comes from
and as long as they've got a reasonable
um background to it i mean if it's
somebody that's contributed
to the subversion to the to the
development then we would
you know put that forward i mean
certainly i guess it's up to the board
to sort of decide this is a good name
this is not
suitable it's a real name
as i understand it though scott the main
the recommendation was to
um um take the um the farm the name of
the farm and it was only
if that wasn't um deemed appropriate
that they would like as a second choice
the
the contractor so um yeah i mean
personally i thought the name of the
farm there's some
significance it fits with the the um
approved criteria for the council policy
and
um and um yeah that was my view
anyone like to put a motion andrew do i
have a seconder for that
thank you john andrew would you like to
speak to it although you really already
have
thank you madam chair for the noting
that fact
i take it as a compliment
no john anything you would like to add
right anything thank you madam chair i
would just like to say that i support
this motion
um my question wasn't indicating i
didn't approve of the original motion
but i think it's preferable to have a
name that's linked
to the community where it's being used
and i thought that name
sounded quite cool i've never heard of
that name before but it obviously has
some significance to the locality
so i think it's very appropriate
right anyone else got anything to say
right i'll put that motion to the vote
all those in favor of grey fern
lane yep say i
those against that's carried thank you
scott
two good reports and um you have a
result so that's always a good
later in the evening thank you
all right we have an application to the
discretionary
fund okay
good evening everyone um
thank goodness it's only one the other
day i had six all in one report which
was quite a marathon
arts canterbury they're not
based in our area they're based in
christchurch but i believe there are
several of our artists who belong to
their organisation
um i did phone and ask them if any of
the artists
chosen to display at this
presentation were from our area and i
didn't
get a definitive answer because i don't
think they had actually
made a decision yet they still in the
setup stage
but having said that um you might
want to look at the finances
but i felt that there was no reason for
me
to phone them and say they didn't meet
the criteria i believe it's up to the
board to make that decision
thanks kate one question
they've received eighteen hundred
dollars in funding says from the wdc
creative communities funding so that is
linked through the council
okay yes i would presume um
pretty sure that it would have come
through as the eight
the annual plan that funding would have
gone to creative communities fund and
then
um i presume the firm would have
applied to creative communities much as
they've applied here creative
communities i think generally
philip you'll know more about it um
they give a fair amount of money it's
not like our little
two three hundred dollar shots
uh thank you excuse me i'm the chair of
creative
communities waimakariri and we have
approved a grant of
eighteen hundred dollars towards this
event
so when i was reading it i'm thinking
that sounds familiar then when i looked
through it confirmed my
thought um creative communities
waimakariri is funded by the department
of internal affairs
and we have a budget of 50 or 60 000 a
year to distribute
so we actually have a bigger budget than
the community board does
um so it is a legitimate event
and it is being held in the district so
it's up to the board to determine
whether it wishes
to assist further
right any other questions from anyone
i would like to move that we declined
funding
for this um would i have a seconder for
that
thank you john um
yeah it would be an event that's held
within our area but that seemed to be
about
about it having picked up
dollars with the funding from the
creative communities
which is administered through the
council i sort of felt
that they had had you know a fear a fair
whack from the
local community this is a
it's arts canterbury it's not just a
waimakariri thing
we have no idea how many artists would
come from up here
so for that reason i just sort of felt
it didn't
really meet our criteria and that there
were other community
things that may be more valuable
john did you want to say anything
from local people we don't know that for
a fact
um and i just sort of feel like um
it sort of looked they don't need our
funding
right anyone else got something to add
if i can
yeah i wasn't quite sure what to make of
it when i um saw this i could see that
that conflict and see it wasn't you know
local like some of the other things like
the
arts event that goes in quiet point what
not but but i sort of thought that um
it's different it is being held locally
and the you can see the local guys out
at brick mill
given the venue for free and and um
and i didn't see the financial
statements for this you can see the
event
is kind of needing the fundraising from
all sorts of parties for the event
i kind of wondered if we should go half
and get them 250 or something like that
because
there is a clear local benefit we have
we're hoping something to happen
locally and it's a wee bit different um
they're not purporting for it to be
about local artists they're performing
it for it to be held locally with a
different collection of artists
and you know i think that's worthy some
[Music]
consideration
yep i'd be happy to put an emotion for
250 dollars to go towards it
sick in that motion madam chair
[Music]
would you like to speak to it
i'm in a grants also with andrew that
yes they're not
uh professing that it will be all local
artists
but if it drives actual further business
to
our other businesses in waikuku
with we have the collectiveness down the
road as an eatery we also have pegasus
down the road as well and if it just
highlights and
showcases our district by new potential
persons
attending then i do advocate 500
no but as andrew said 250 be more than
happy to support it
thank you madam chair anybody else got
anything to add
yeah i i mean i would have to to vote
against that as i said i still
support the the the declining the
application
um where they're sort of looking for
money from
they seem to be looking for a lot from
the waimakariri
district um and i sort of think that
they should also be looking
into christchurch because there will be
christchurch artists things like that um
yeah anyone else got anything they'd
like to add
john um having listened to what andrea
said
i think i sort of sort of agree with
andrew's
suggestion is um there could be a good
off spin-off from this whole thing
so i don't think well there's any reason
why we shouldn't support it
thank you madam chair um given my
other hat i'm supposed to promote the
arts
and my macaroni and i think this isn't
about the artists
it's about the exhibition and most of
the people will be local who would
attend that
there could be out-of-towners from
christchurch
so i'm happy to support the amendment i
think it
adds to vibrancy in the district um
and whether there are local artists or
not i think isn't
really the point of the exhibition
right anyone else before we vote on that
right i'll put that amended motion to
the vote which is 250
all those in favor say aye those against
and me so that vote is
carried
so amendments carried now we have to
move to the substantive motion so
all those in favor say aye those against
that's carried thank you very much
everybody
so it's 250k
meeting dates
sorry
[Music]
yes normal end of year reported
just setting up your meetings following
the same
pattern as this year other than
hopefully
a hiccup between may and june
april and june
you will notice that the 9th of february
was
will be a tuesday because of watangida
so because it's a tuesday we've opted to
go to waikuku beach
because they have a permanent fixture on
a monday so
if we're wanting to meet at waikoku we
have to change our meeting that scene we
have to already
i've taken the opportunity of suggesting
waikoku for that meeting
and the others just follow the normal
wooden pegasus
and if we decide to
go somewhere else we can do an amended
motion at that time
um pleased
that well i'm hoping that you're going
to stay at 6 pm because i think it's
made a huge difference
to the outcomes of our meetings
and any questions i'm happy to answer
andrew thanks um okay
and um just my main question was would
we go
um why does sefton not appear as one of
the options
on there i did hear what you said is if
we want to go another thing we could
make a
choice but i thought that was good um
and just curious again they've got a
permanent
booking for monday so we'd have to
change the meeting date again to tuesday
but we can do that there's no problem
and also i wasn't sure
what their timeline is going to be like
next year if
with the new build and all that i know
that they're saying probably two years
but i wasn't going to be
super confident but if we if we decide
we can look at maybe
october again or next year
i just asked a question um
couldn't we couldn't we actually just
sort of decide that
next year when it comes around that we
we
we swap something around we don't have
to make a decision now like
yeah yeah
although um i think um in some ways i
think
it'd be good to have that in the in the
calendar i think it's quite you know
it takes a bit of effort for us to go
somewhere else because we've got these
good facilities they're close at hand
and whatnot
and in some ways also the tuesday if
we've got enough notice
um like october um we
and anyone else can be well aware of it
and by the way we don't we don't know
it's probably not an issue but we might
find that some people
might be committed on monday and it's a
bit more difficult for them to come
along um i'm
not really suggesting that a serious
issue but but it doesn't
it's not the end of the world i think it
may be some little advantage in having a
um a variety once or twice a year so you
personally i
just questioned i'd like to see a
scheduler sefton
um meeting sometime if we can
if it's not in the summer would be good
look i put that on the
night when we had the one at sift and i
couldn't i touched rugby that night so i
couldn't go to if it's in the winter
that would be fine but
generally on a tuesday or now
good question 15 minutes
which one you should exist yesterday
every monday at 7 o'clock teaching
sometimes i go into the other room
i'm sorry i went away but we're
generally here on the monday
soon okay
we won't be too late
health and well-being
i suppose with sefton
i suppose with stefan the issue is
whether we actually set a date or
whether we actually wait until next year
and actually see where their time frames
are at
as it sits with um you know the hall
because it might be that there is
actually a really good time of the year
when
you know we might actually get some
members of the public along to the
meeting
you know when the whole committee is
actually discussing something
so yeah it might be better to wait until
next year to actually set the date but
actually
sort of say that we would like to have a
meeting in sefton next year
it's an option what i can do
is make a note and maybe bring it back
to the board in march
and just remind them and then we can
review it then
okay when does the touch season start
the only reason why we sort of looked at
um
october november december was because
the room's quite cold
um and and it's dark so
you know we're trying to get for summer
so it could either be
there or through to april
it doesn't look like those dates clash
but um
i think the one we had at sift and
cliches was the full council
on a tuesday so if you do that's the
first tuesday it doesn't look like any
of
the first tuesday of the month
well i don't know no it doesn't look
like they will only the 8th of march
might but you know
and perhaps like september if we you
know
early it's not that far off spring
good jacket i can share if anyone else
needs it
so i could move that we we stuck with
the dates as they are here
but that we note that k will bring
something back
to the board early next year when we
re-look at it because we would like to
have a meeting at sefton
um would i have a seconder for that
thank you andrew any other comments
around that
um i'd like to pick up on your
suggestion madam chair which that that
date is okay i think you'll do it anyway
but with discussion with the um
committee up here because there might be
a timing that's suitable for them
and it might work the other way if we
said we were coming it might encourage
them to do
to sort of focus on something again
anybody else got anything to add to that
right i'll put that to the vote all
those in favor say aye
those against that's carried
right correspondence we
[Applause]
have a memo from colin roxburgh regards
to the question that we had from a
sefton resident around the
ashley water supply
anybody have any questions around that
okay to you madam chair
i have forwarded this correspondence
to um to the gentleman who wrote to our
conscious
jonathan call carl
and i've asked him if he had any further
questions to come back to me that was
probably
two weeks ago and i haven't heard
anything so i'm presuming he's
happy with the response i'm still
waiting for
um the query regarding speeding
from joanne i did send her a reminder
last week
but i think they're pretty pushed at the
moment with getting
shovel ready projects up and running
so i will follow that up again
um thank you for that kay can i just
affirm though that
even if we are busy that there's still
some personal contact to acknowledge
receipt thank you
all right any other questions anyone
like to me that we received that
correspondence thank you phillip
john seconding philip anything you'd
like to say
just that i think it was really a
question uh
directed more at hironui than ourselves
anything anyone else would like to say
write all those in favor say aye
those against that's carried
cheers report i'll take it as read any
questions from anyone
i will move from the chair that my
report be accepted
do i have a seconder for that
andrew i don't think i've got anything
to add
it's pretty self
explanatory i don't think there was
anything major there
um andrew anything you'd like to add
anything from anyone else right
i'll put that to the vote all those in
favor say aye those against
that one's carried right matters of
information there's a fair list of
reports here anyone have any questions
around any of them
anyone like to put a motion to receive
those
philip thank you do i have a second for
that
thank you sandra any discussion
hello i was just going to comment that
one of the reports relate to the
relates in 9.12 and sandra may wish to
comment on that too the property
maintenance by-law
which went it's taken a long time
but essentially it now relates only to
long grass
and long grass is uh 200
millimeters um
where the council if you don't cut your
grass
it applies to vacant urban sections
residential
sections not not rural areas uh
the council can come and cut it and uh
send you the bill
so um it's quite a good we buy law
it's fairly arbitrary as to what the
length of grass should be but
um apparently this was quite influential
in determining the height of grass
that's very scientific very scientific
thank you
i do have a question around that
actually i'd actually forgotten but
um in pegasus which was
one of the problem children of the
district in terms of
of empty sections although they are
getting less every day which is really
good
um but also one of the other thing is
the swale
which is the equivalent to the berm
which is council responsibility
although residents are expected to
maintain it
will this apply to that this by-law
apply to that
no it applies to residential sections
only
which will be in private ownership it
doesn't apply to council messages
so maybe snap send soul may deal with
that issue
yes i find it quite ironic though that
that we're expecting private residents
to to maintain their empty section
and you know we have to do a snapseed
solve to get council to
maintain the swell in front of an empty
section
because i'll tell you a lot of them are
probably about four times the height of
that
so
simon can i just get to your
summer reading list the customer
satisfaction survey results
but it is a really rich um
the value of that survey is
also
is
thanks simon um in regard to that
uh just to note that
um there will be a presentation on the
customer services
at the new at the next all boards um
tessa surly is going to be
there to take us through it and give you
an opportunity to actually ask questions
[Music]
i can tell you simon i've already read
it
um very um surprised at the low
response relatively low response rate
that's um
to it you know overall you know
yeah it's also but it's also quite a low
number that are actually
put out there yeah
at the district level it is about plus
or minus fours
yeah so
pretty pretty good
yeah that is true yeah
no any other questions from anyone would
someone like to move that we receive
that information
it's been moved we've done that we're
waiting too well
right well i'll put that motion then all
those in favor say aye
goes against that's carried members
information exchange
andrew do you want to kick off with
anything you've got to
no thanks andrew
andrea
yes andrea has there been a meeting of
the
health advisory group is there anything
no i was just wondering if there'd been
anything
strategy
right phillip anything you would like to
share with us
um just i'll highlight a couple of
things
um the health advisory committee met
last month i think
i wasn't able to attend its meeting in
december
at the hospital yeah so it is alive and
well
um one of the things no pun intended
it is a birthing unit um creative new
zealand assessments we've already
mentioned that this evening
um that committee made a number of
decisions and i think allocated about
thirty thousand dollars in round figures
at its meeting last month
um
the property acquisition and disposals
working group has been meeting
there was a group i may have mentioned
previously we were looking at disposals
but before you can dispose of a property
that may be surplus you need to know
how it was acquired and it's quite a
complicated
scenario how council has ended up owning
various properties last month
i was fortunate to go to the zone five
and six
conference in ashburton and councillor
barnett
and the mayor were in attendance also
i started making notes and then i
discovered that kirsten was busy typing
away on her
laptop so i actually printed some of her
notes off
rather than take my own
so we met the new president of local
government new zealand
and they've also got a new ce susan
freeman green
so it's had a wee bit of a refresh i
guess
they talked about water
social media the future of local
government
um and really a whole lot of
items it was really a good event we had
a number of mayors
from throughout the south island a lot
of quite hard cases
but just to network with people and talk
to people in other areas was very
worthwhile
i went to art on the key they had a
pottery exhibition
also partly funded by creative new
zealand
waimakariri i also went to um
the rata annual function about a week
ago
and robin wallace is now the chair of
the trustees for rata and uh one of my
former
associates michael bendel uh who works
in kaiapoi is also a trustee
so north canterbury is quite well served
i think i'm on the board
civil defence um sarah stuart black
who is the national controller if i'm
calling it the right thing
affectionately known as norm came and
spent a morning um
in rangiora with the council and uh
in fact she was only supposed to be an
hour but i think she stayed two hours
um one of the things she said was well
we've had six years of disasters
in the last six years why do we think
it'll be any different
in the next six years that was the good
news
yeah so i thought well she's probably
quite right actually we always think
things will get better
but on our track record in history maybe
we should plan
for you know not so happy events
in the future um i also went to the
north canterbury sport and recreation
trust where i'm
one of the council representatives
they announce naming rights for stadium
waimakariri
it's now to be known as main power
stadium and mcalpine's have sponsored
the four indoor courts
so they're both significant sponsorships
and will help the sport and recreation
trust
complete its fifth out of the building
i went to a kids canned fundraiser
um the other night with the chair of the
kaiapoi tuahiwee
community board the mayor and also
noticed that the president of the
pegasus
residence group was participating as
well
what was that one oh i did a site visit
to a dairy farm
down the road that we're having some
issues um
and there is a buffer in the district
plan
for effluent spreading so there was an
issue there
and i actually did a snapseed solve over
in pegasus the other day where
i saw a tree that had been partly
knocked over
i haven't been back to see if it's been
righted yet but
it's on the road just opposite the shops
heading towards the lake
just past the good home um
yeah yeah it was on about a 45 degree
angle
a car or something may have hit by the
look of things
but anyhow that's enough for me so
that's it
thank you watery stuff
you'll be perhaps interested we get
the water zone committee get a regular
complaints about the algae
on pines beach
from one concerned kai for individual
to the extent the councils investigated
to the tune of
tens of thousands of dollars in fact
it's probably heading towards about 80
or 90 000
to see what is in the algae and the foam
around it
um to no avail in the sense that nothing
nothing really toxic's been found or
nothing's been found
and anyway john cook who represents
is now a member of the um water zone
committee and made the comment
um last week at the meeting that
in his youth which is some time ago but
he was he lived at pines and he surfed
for 25 years there
and he's waded through up to one metre
deep
and picked off his board various
different
colors of algae and foam over the years
and he's still alive to tell it
so um so 25 years of that
he he actually dismisses it as a concern
which
um really effectively we have as well
um the kaiapoi river which as you know
is the most
polluted river in north canterbury and
probably canterbury
is now as a result of the nps
fresh water which became into legal
effect in
september ecan is now going to put
continuous monitoring equipment in fact
some equipment which is the first for
new zealand
on one of the piers of the mandeville
bridge
and by the end of january and it'll be
there continuously monitoring a whole
raft of water quality parameters
and i quote adrian meredith's as saying
is acknowledged that as a nutrient
sensitive
receiving environment exhibiting many
problems ecan cannot ignore it anymore
so this is a great step forward
i'm your biodiversity champion um
i might have told you that last time i
can't recall uh and as
as your biodiversity champion um
and these are one representative
for all the territorial authorities in
the canterbury region that we will
seems to be an initiative through the
mayoral forum coordinated by
environment canterbury that we're having
a meeting before christmas once
some ecan counselor lan
farm has her um fam has her baby
um you will have seen the naitahu
statement of claim over freshwater and
pc7 hearings
that continue next week their week on
week off
and next week we've got the council
and me and they conclude
in december when there will be a period
when the
three commissioners compile the report
and i suspect
something will come out first quarter
perhaps of
of 2021.
that's about it thank you
meetings
and we talked about the signs other
lines what we're doing over here so
we're just waiting for those sitting to
get prepared and then i'll put the thing
through for the health and safety plan
for the contractor the signage for the
welcome signs i'm just trying to get
someone to make them
for nothing basically um so that's going
slowly but that will happen
um we also decided that we're going to
have a what in
the community cultural day like we did
last year with the school so this year
we have a bbq instead of a hunger
because it's
logistically it's a bit easier to
organize
um and the other things i had i think
would come into the long-term plan
about roading and
footpaths okay thanks man john
oh i think you've got more
yes i'm afraid i forgot to circulate i'm
terribly sorry john
but john did very nicely send me one
just after i sent out
an apology to you um but he did send it
and
i prepared it and made it all pretty in
that and then i forgot to
forward it on so i'm terribly sorry
i'll i'll flick it up tomorrow could you
include that
could you include that
dropping for the wood ins um walking and
cycling
um on the 8th and then
with our acceptance meeting at the hall
which i enjoyed
oh that's where i was
then i attended a sustainable
strategy in the town hall
on the
i'm going to get mixed up here on one
i've got an appointment at the urology
department
and then i had
it's been good and then i had a meeting
at the
war memorial site of the uh with the rsa
and the the woody and lions and we
discussed
um the seating and the signage
and it was a really good meeting and
neil price from the
rsa he made the suggestion
that the fence between the footpath
and the preserve has pulled out he says
um they've never had any problem and he
said it's actually just
cuts down the congregation area in half
so i think that was a good suggestion
um and so i i had prepared a plan the
same but then it sent something off
anyway
so the seats um are going to be located
and i think mark we're going to be
looking at someone to install them
upward
they're really good seats and the signs
actually really good too
um where else was i
and i went to attended a echo workshop
in the town hall which was all about
home insulation and things like that
and i think that'll just about do it
i think there's other things i do will
come in next month
thanks right consultation projects
two of which listed here have closed um
we still have the draft climate change
policy open until the 13th of november
as a board we haven't done anything if
you want to do something as an
individual
please go right ahead another
current consultation which we'll talk
about
at the end after the meeting is the
plane change theory
relating to ravenswood and it opened
today and closes on the 4th of december
so if we want to do
a submission to that we may have to do a
workshop but we will discuss that later
there is also upcoming an application
for an on licence for the bunker cafe
and bar
in in pegasus um
andrew's already said he he does not um
he's in support of it he has no problems
with it so
you know if anybody wants the board to
look at putting a submission in
um you know please let me know it hasn't
i don't think it's been advertised yet i
don't think i've seen it yet so
um there is still time so you know if
you want to
the board can talk about it but
otherwise again you're always
welcome um to put in a personal
submission
and that is an on license which we have
talked about before that we feels
different from an off licence um
so those are the consultation projects
andrew
note also i think um council redmond
made the same comment
as my understanding is my point was
twofold which is i'd actually given a
character reference to one of the
to the manager so i wanted to make that
clear and i wasn't sure
um i know you know i feel like you're
very good about ducking out when there's
sort of things come into play but i
didn't see that as being
um it's on the table anyway if there's
any issue but the other point that both
philip and i raised was that
um there's a license there already it's
just as i understand there's a change in
the name of the entity that's going to
be doing it
there might be some other other issues
but i saw that as being quite different
in nature than
starting someone starting a fresh and
selling as an off license yeah
patient projects um board funding update
um
we had 4094 we've spent 250
tonight general landscaping fund it's
just over 13 000
but i'm sure we'll be revisiting that
coming up media items i think i can
find something from tonight anybody you
think want me to highlight
particularly we have no questions
understanding orders we have no urgent
general
business so i will close this formal
part of the meeting our next meeting is
um 6 p.m and we're at the pegasus
community centre where we haven't been
for some time
but please note it is on monday the 7th
of december which is actually
the first monday of the month not the
not the second
and i think that's just simply because
it is december is that right
so thank you for that everyone
you